اذا مشاهدينا قطعوا شريان التمويل
الايراني هدف يضاهي باهميته خطوط شاحنات
اسلحتها وطريق عبورها للميليشيات كذلك حيث
فرضت وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه عقوبات على
تسعه وثلاثين كيانا تساعد ايران على
التهرب من العقوبات واشنطن وصفت تلك
كيانات بشبكه ظل مصرفي التي توفر عشرات
المليارات من الدولارات للنظام الايراني
سنويا الشبكه هي واحده من عده انظمه تمويل
غير مشروعه تمنح الكيانات الايرانيه
الخاضعه للعقوبات مثل صناعه
البتروكيماويات قدره الوصول الى النظام
المالي العالمي والتعتيم على تجارتهم مع
العملاء الاجانب وكانت الولايات المتحده
اضافت الى قائمه العقوبات امس مسؤولين
ايرانيين وشركات على خلفيه اتهامات
بارتكاب انتهاكات جسيمه لحقوق الانسان
يذكر مشاهدينا ان نظام الظل المصرفي هو
مجموعه من الوسطاء الماليين غير المصرفيين
الذين يقدمون خدمات مماثله للبنوك
التجاريه التقليديه
[موسيقى]